Hey webslingers it's Charlie!o big news Tom
Holland is our new Spider-Man regain his see
him for like the next four movies probably
avengers infinity Ward to in case you have
no idea what I'm talking about Marvel just
confirmed that Tom Holland is going to be
the new Spider-Man and then will go on to
do a new Spider-Man trilogy at Sony starting
in 2017 you have no idea who Tom Holland is
you never seen a before Wolf Hall is like
that the biggest thing that is done recently
but he also he actually just made a movie
with Thor which is kind of funny with Chris
Hemsworth it's called in the heart of the
see it's not out till December so you coming
you can't see it yet but you can go see it
later this year I just think it's funny the
way the avengers bump into each other when
they're doing other movies like Robert Downey
Junior and Mark Ruffalo doing zodiac way before
they ever did the avengers together that was
actually Robert Downey Junior did that movie
before he became Ironman the director they
picked for the first Spider-Man film is also
relative unknown his name is Jon Watts he
did this movie called cop car that is going
to be out in August is a like a huge studio
blockbuster film or anything like that Marvel
just continuing the tradition of raising new
talent rather than picking you know big stars
right now Sony is going to have to live with
these people for like the next three Spider-Man
films you know that is unless they they pick
a new director for the sequels but Marvel
deserves a lot of the credit for picking these
unknown actors and directors there's a couple
reasons they do that one it's really expensive
to hire the biggest star in the biggest directors
in the planet so they find someone new that
the pan way less the other big reason is because
they're looking for fresh voice like when
you hire Steven Spielberg to direct all your
movies you get a good movie but it's going
to be his story every single time that was
one of the big criticisms when JJ Abrams was
picked to direct the new Star Wars film is
like does JJ Abrams get to re-envision the
entire sci-fi movie universe for the planet
now Marvel very wisely doesn't pick any one
person to do every single movie that they
do is much as these are big franchise films
and you can predict a lot of what the plot
is going to be each new director bring something
fresh to the characters really the best example
of Marvel raising new talent is with Robert
Downey Junior and Ironman he done a whole
bunch of stuff he had this huge career behind
abuse a child actor when they hired him his
career was on life support any was almost
uninsurable studios can't hire actors they
can ensure them behind the camera James Gunn
is probably like the best success story he
had a really solid track record with his smaller
movies but you know guarding the galaxy very
different story hundred and $50 million giant
studio film Marvel's real talent is in finding
like really amazing talented creative people
and raising them up giving them opportunities
James Gunn even set you throughout the whole
process of making guardians of the galaxy
Mart Marvel had this giant support system
in place but he was largely left to his own
devices to find that the creative voice of
the film what Marvel does is is they provide
the support system if you need help with the
writing or any the practical aspects of production
anything you feel like you need help with
to get the movie made they don't like Jan
their hands up directors Bunsen and finger
puppet them around which might happen in other
studios given that billions of dollars are
on the line of Ernie done a couple Spider-Man
Civil War videos but the biggest?
This whole time is the actor that they're
going to go with because that that will largely
inform what the characters can look like all
the best actors a really open to direction
but I feel like young actors actually learned
a lot more on said just because they don't
have the work history that older actors do
so even if you don't feel like Tom Holland
is is ready for like the crazy action of an
avengers franchise Marvel and Sony can train
him to do that when he's got the mask on they
can totally put a stunt person in there and
just have him do voiceover ever since then
announce this Sony Marvel collaboration with
Spider-Man Kevin fight he's been talking about
his vision for the Spider-Man character though
will be the most classic wisecracking quit
being version of the character that you can
remember my mind since I'm a younger person
goes to Ben disses ultimate Spider-Man run
I would just read that because of the high
school Peter Parker that feels like a high
school Peter Parker Spider-Man is a superhero
but for the most part he's a kid in high school
so you can experience a lot of typical highschooler
problems that's really what's going to set
him apart from these other avengers characters
in a you guys are all probably wondering what
the dynamic is going to be between him and
the other avengers because will be like almost
too old to be considered his big brothers
most of the actors the play the avengers in
real life you not including like Mark Ruffalo
Robert Junior are in their early to mid 30s
I mean there's still pretty younger but there
quite a bit older Robert Downey Junior is
almost old enough to be Tom Holland's father
see you can guess how they might play on that
idea and Capt.
America Civil War in the comic books and comic
books Civil War Spider-Man is a little bit
closer to Tony Stark in aging and Capt.
America so there, like big brothers the movie
seems like it's widening that gap so you have
Capt.
America dad versus Ironman dad but for the
most part I'm not expecting Spider-Man to
have the same role in Civil War as he did
in the comics remember Marvel's job is is
just introduce the character in give you an
idea for with the tone is going to be then
he'll go on to the Sony franchise with that
with a really develop them really feel like
if you want to compare Capt.
America Civil War to the comics yet the think
of the Spider-Man role more is going to Black
Panther because that's Marvel's character
that they own 100% of Vibranium is now the
most precious resource in the Marvel universe
so naturally Black Panther being the person
who controls access to that is going to be
a very important person to the avengers I
mean thing about it Ironman builds himself
a new suit every single movie why wouldn't
the next one be Vibranium but for all intents
and purposes expect to see Spider-Man in a
you know a relatively minor but important
role in Civil War and other was a lot of question
about you know which Marvel movie was you
show up in first the idea is is that he would
show up in a Marvel movie first then go on
to the Sony franchise that means that he has
to be in a Marvel movie in 2016 Capt.
America Civil War is just the most logical
place to put them that's why they were really
down to the wire with this casting choice
there was still like three or four actors
on the list last week there about halfway
done filming Capt.
America Civil War so they're going to put
them in the movie they had to pick actor fast
picking actor for franchise that big is like
buying a billion-dollar house you just hope
you made the right investment and a lot of
your asking what changes they're making from
Civil War the comic book that was all about
identity the superhero registration act gun
control Civil War the movie is more about
accountability think about the collateral
damage in avengers age of Ultron Ultron goes
on a rampage the hogans of destroying half
of Johannesburg who is accountable for that
how do the avengers fix that Robert Downey
Junior actually said something interesting
on his Facebook page like it like in real
life he said he felt like Tony Stark paid
to repair all that damage from the whole fight
that makes sense but but then think about
it inside the Marvel universe you have all
the governments of the world looking at the
avengers and what's going on the unit's massive
stakes the want to be able to hold the avengers
accountable for what they do because is much
as they save the world they also destroy it
code Green was one of my favorite new hold
things from each of Ultron that was so much
fun.
My big question for you guys how do you feel
about Tom Holland being Spider-Man for the
next seven years remember we have next year's
Marvel movie that we have three Spider-Man
movies for the next six years after that as
weird as it might feel for the end of to pick
such a young actor for Peter Parker think
about it this way he's not can it age out
of the role by the time they get to that third
Spider-Man movie he'll still be in his 20s
but I'll probably do for my next Marvel video
is like my favorite Spider-Man villains ides
I haven't done that many Spider-Man videos
recently and and now feels like a totally
appropriate time now that we have a new Spider-Man
and congratulations to this week's giveaway
winter I'm actually going to do my DC giveaway
in this to just just in case I forget or it
takes me to long to get my DC video out this
week Kuno and Ashton Babiste you guys win
$20 Amazon gift cards I'll remind you guys
again whenever I post my next Flash video
that'll probably be like the next video that
I post be sure to private message me on my
channel so I can get your guys contact info
but I will be doing your flashing arrow videos
this week I know last week I didn't do an
Arrow video Now that we're through the game
of thrones corridor I can I can ease off of
that and start doing some more comic book
stuff, comic con is in a couple weeks so I'll
start doing some, comic con preview videos
next week maybe the week after that so while
you guys wait for that stuff to post in case
you didn't see it Darth Vader and Ahsoka Tano
were on Star Wars Rebels this past weekend
you can click here for my breakdown of that
episode it was bad ass Darth Vader tore shit
up for an entire hour and you can click here
to learn all about resurrection in the game
of thrones universe thank you so much for
watching, everybody let's High Five and I'll
see you guys tomorrow!